bevor es mit einem neuen Fall losgeht
erstmal danke für eure ganze
Unterstützung und all die lieben
Nachrichten die ihr uns per Mail oder
Instagram sendet wenn euch gefällt was
wir hier machen lasst uns eine Bewertung
und einen Kommentar da und aktiviert die
Glocke danke schön
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen True Crime
Podcast von Bild bei mir ist wie immer
Toni Heyer und bei mir Mirko Kasimir
hallo Mirko hallo Toni heute erzählen
wir die Geschichte von Adam boscout
einem Unternehmer aus dem hessischen Bad
Nauheim vor allem aber ein liebevoller
Vater und Ehemann mit gerade einmal 45
Jahren wird er aus dem Leben gerissen
und hinterlässt Frau und zwei Töchter
wir steigen diesmal ganz steil ein Mirko
erzähl mal 8 April 1997 gegen 4:30 Uhr
morgens werden Polizei und Notarzt zu
einer Landstraße in der Nähe der
Raststätte Wetterau an der A5 zwischen
Gießen und Frankfurt am Main gerufen
ein schwarzer BMW ist von der Landstraße
abgekommen und gegen einen Baum geprallt
als polizei- und Rettungskräfte
eintreffen ist der Fahrer bereits tot
sein Name Adem boscourt für die
Angehörigen bricht eine Welt zusammen
vor allem für seine beiden Töchter im
Teenageralter sie haben ihren Vater
geliebt und verehrt sein Tod kommt so
plötzlich so unvorhergesehen so
scheinbar sinnlos die beiden sind völlig
fertig ein tragischer Unfall so scheint
es es ist schrecklich das zu sagen aber
einer Alltag in Deutschland bis ich 2014
eine anonyme Anruferin meldet und
behauptet Adam boscout wurde ermordet
aus einem Verkehrsunfall wird nach 17
Jahren der Mordfall Adam boscout
Adam boscourt kommt als 18-Jähriger aus
der Türkei nach Deutschland und geht
hier als Konditor in die Lehre doch er
hat größere Pläne er wechselt die
Branche baut über die Jahre ein
erfolgreiches Reinigungsunternehmen auf
seine Firma hat mehrere Angestellte und
betreut die Toiletten und Duschen an
sechs Autobahnraststätten eine davon ist
die Raststätte Wetterau kaum drei
Kilometer vom Wohnhaus der Familie
entfernt die Boss kurz wohnen zu dieser
Zeit in einem Mehrfamilienhaus im
hessischen Bad Nauheim das ist ein
Kurort am Ostrand des Taunus früher sind
hier prominente ein- und ausgegangen zum
Beispiel Otto von Bismarck Kaiser
Wilhelm I und der russische Zahn
Nikolaus II 1898 erholt sich Kaiserin
Elisabeth von Österreich und Ungarn bis
er bekannt als Sissi hier bevor sie
keine zwei Wochen nach ihrer Abreise in
Genf ermordet wird
in einer hessischen Kleinstadt
aber eben nicht irgendeiner hessischen
Kleinstadt von Oktober 1958 bis März
1960 lebt sogar Elvis Presley in Bad
Nauheim naja aber eher aus Zufall er ist
als Wehrdienstleistender im benachbarten
Friedberg stationiert in den 80er Jahren
verblasst der glanzte Städtchens aber
Bad Nauheim ist noch immer ein guter Ort
zum Leben ein guter Ort um eine Familie
zu gründen und Kinder groß zu ziehen ein
guter Ort um eine Existenz aufzubauen
adam boscout hat all das erreicht als er
am frühen Morgen des 8 April 1997 in
sein Auto steigt einen schwarzen BMW
sein Ziel ist die Raststätte Wetterau
eine kurze Fahrt auf der Landstraße
durch ein kurzes Waldstück vorbei an
einem Segelflugplatz und einem
ehemaligen hofgestüt direkt zur
Raststätte unzählige Male ist er diesen
Weg gefahren doch heute kommt er nicht
an
der schwarze BMW pragt gegen einen Baum
nur etwa 600 Meter von Adams Ziel der
Raststätte entfernt Polizei und Notarzt
können nur noch den Tod feststellen die
Einschätzung vor Ort Alleinunfall ohne
Fremdbeteiligung der Notarzt macht vor
Ort eine Leichenschau die Verletzungen
scheinen mit dem Unfallgeschehen
übereinzustimmen Genickbruch trägt er
als Todesursache in das Formular ein
Sachverständige untersuchen das
Unfallfahrzeug prüfen ob das Auto
fahrtauglich war ob die Bremsen
funktioniert und dergleichen sie können
keine Mängel oder Manipulationen
feststellen Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft Teilen mit der
45-Jährige sei nicht angeschnallt
gewesen als sein Fahrzeug von der Straße
abkam und gegen einen Baum Breite der
Fall wird als normaler Verkehrsunfall zu
den aktengelegt traurige Routine
hunderte Menschen sterben Jahr für Jahr
in Deutschland bei Zusammenstößen mit
Bäumen bei allem Leid und aller Trauer
eines Tages können Angehörigen
hoffentlich irgendwie mit dem Verlust
umgehen und ihr Leben weiterleben können
ihren Frieden machen in dem Wissen dass
der Mensch den sie so geliebt haben und
immer lieben werden seinen Frieden
gefunden hat Adam boscout wird in seiner
alten Heimat im türkischen Izmir
bestattet sein Tod bleibt als Unfall in
Erinnerung und auch wenn die Trauer nie
vergehen wird die Angehörigen vor allem
adems Töchter lernen irgendwie damit zu
leben sein Tod war sinnlos aber sein
Leben war es nicht und das ist es woran
sie sicher erinnern wollen und dann 2014
reist eine anonyme Anruferin die Wunden
wieder auf sie behauptet Adam boscout
wurde durch einen Genickschuss in seinem
Wagen ermordet und die Tat als Unfall
getarnt und jetzt 17 Jahre nach dem Tod
ihres Vaters müssen Adams Töchter einen
weiteren Schock verkraften eine von
ihnen sagt im Interview mit Bild
er ist zum zweiten Mal gestorben nur
schlimmer weil den Unfall den
akzeptierst du aber einen Mord den
kannst du nicht akzeptieren eine
wirklich grausame Vorstellung das
bisschen Frieden dass man vielleicht
gefunden hat so wieder zu verlieren
absolut da geht ja die Gedankenmaschine
wieder von vorne los die ganze Trauer
noch mal von Anfang an ja aber bis jetzt
ist das erstmal nur ein anonymer Anruf
kann man der Frau am Telefon glauben was
weiß sie wirklich und warum meldet sie
sich erst jetzt nach 17 Jahren
sie selbst sagt dass sie keine
Augenzeugen sei sondern nur durch
Hörensagen erfahren habe dass der
vermeintliche Unfall in Wirklichkeit
einen brutaler Mord war trotz aller
Fragen ein solcher Anruf wird natürlich
ernst genommen die Staatsanwaltschaft
geht der Behauptung der Frau nach und
prüft die Akten und bald finden sich
Hinweise dass es sich tatsächlich um
einen Mord gehandelt hat da ist zum
Beispiel die Art der Blutspuren im Auto
mit Abstand und mit der neuen
Fragestellung fällt auf dass sie nicht
zu dem angenommenen Unfall eines
einzelnen Fahrers passen außerdem wurde
der Beifahrer Airbag ausgelöst und das
passiert nur wenn ein gewisses Gewicht
auf dem Sitz lastet also in der Regel
wenn ein Beifahrer dort sitzt von nun an
ermitteln Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft
wegen des Anfangsverdachts eines
Tötungsdelikts
okay ihr fragt euch jetzt bestimmt warum
das nicht gleich aufgefallen ist und wie
ein Genickschuss als Genickbruch
diagnostiziert werden konnte also ich
habe mich das zumindest gefragt als ich
das das erste Mal gehört habe und
natürlich das war ein Versäumnis das
hätte bemerkt werden müssen ich will es
auch gar nicht entschuldigen aber man
darf auch nicht vergessen dass die
Rettungskräfte und Polizisten keine
Veranlassung hatten von einem Mord
auszugehen die waren dafür nicht
sensibilisiert und vielleicht auch nicht
entsprechend ausgebildet sie wurden zu
einem Verkehrsunfall gerufen und haben
das alles mit dieser ich sag jetzt
einfach mal Brille betrachtet und
allgemein gilt hinterher ist man immer
schlauer der Oberstaatsanwalt Thomas
hauburger sagt in Achtung Fahndung es
war ja sogar so dass der Medizin ja auch
keine äußerlichen Verletzungen groß
festgestellt hat und wir gehen ja auch
davon aus dass der oder die Täter eine
kleinkalibrige Waffe verwandt haben und
den anderen bosskoppels Genuss getötet
haben und da kann es sein das ist nur zu
ganz wenig Blutaustritt kommt jetzt aber
laufen die Ermittlungen auf Hochtouren
2016 wird die Leiche Art im Boss kurz in
Izmir exumiert der schreckliche Verdacht
bestätigt sich die Ermittler finden eine
tödliche Schusswunde Adam boscout wurde
ermordet
nach so langer Zeit gestalten sich die
Ermittlungen natürlich sehr sehr
schwierig aber mit Oberstaatsanwalt
Thomas hauburger ist genau der richtige
Mann mit dem Fall betraut 2017 zum
Beispiel konnten eher sein Team und die
hessische Polizei den Mordfall der
kleinen Johanna lösen
1999 kam das achtjährige Mädchen nicht
vom Spiel nach Hause er ist 7 Monate
später wurde ihre Leiche mehr als 100 km
von ihrem zu Hause entfernt gefunden die
Ermittlungen führten zu keinem Ergebnis
2016 wurde der Fall Johanna schließlich
Routine mäßig neu aufgerollt Thomas
hauburger liest die Akten digitalisieren
und beauftragte drei junge
Kriminalbeamte mit unverstellten Blick
auf den Fall zu schauen mit neuen Ideen
und Fragen und ein wenig Glück konnte
2017 der Mörder gefunden und 2018
verurteilt werden der Mordfall Adam
boscout wird jetzt noch einmal unter die
Lupe genommen es gibt ballistische die a
und faseruntersuchungen alles was der
kriminalistische Besteckkasten hergibt
man versucht den vermeintlichen
Unfallwagen zu finden doch dabei hat man
leider kein Glück man kann seine Spuren
nur noch bis zu einem Schrottplatz in
Polen verfolgen anhand von
Zeugenaussagen kann der vermutliche
Tatverlauf rekonstruiert werden irgendwo
auf dem Weg zur Raststätte müssen ein
oder zwei Täter zu Adam boscout in den
Wagen gestiegen sein vielleicht kannte
er sie und ahnte nicht schlimmes
vielleicht haben sie ihn aber auch
gezwungen oder überwältigt in der Nähe
des Baumes an dem der Wagen schließlich
gefunden wurde muss ihm der Mörder von
hinten ins Genick geschossen haben aber
wer waren der oder die Täter hatte Adam
boscout Feinde liegt hier das Motiv für
die Tat schnell taucht der Verdacht auf
dass Adam Boss kurz Tod mit seinem
Geschäft zusammenhängen könnte in den
90er Jahren versuchen Kriminelle an
deutschen Autobahnraststätten das große
Geld mit kleinen oder großen Geschäfte
Reisenden zu machen man spricht hier von
der sogenannten toilettenmafia geld
stinkt nicht heißt es zumindest der
römische Kaiser Vespasian hat den Spruch
geprägt als er eine Steuer für die
Benutzung öffentlicher Toiletten erhob
aber die Geschäftspraktiken einiger
toilettenbetreiber in den 1990ern
stinkend zum Himmel die Reinigungskräfte
werden gnadenlos ausgebeutet das Geld
das die Besucher Ihnen als
Benutzungsgebühr und Trinkgeld auf die
Teller legen müssen viele von ihnen zum
allergrößten Teil abgeben ihnen selbst
bleibt kaum genug zum leben oft sind sie
keine Angestellten sondern als
selbstständige Unternehmer registriert
um Sozialabgaben zu sparen
kamen die Mörder vielleicht aus diesem
Milieu ganz wichtig an dieser Stelle
Adem boscourt hatte mit so etwas nichts
zu tun und war an solchen Kriminellen
und unmoralischen Praktiken nicht
beteiligt aber vielleicht war das ja den
schwarzen Schafen der Branche ein Dorn
im Auge oder war es simpler
Expansionsdrang wolltens skrupellose
Ausbeuter die Raststätten übernehmen an
den bis jetzt Adam Ross kurzfirma die
Toiletten betreute es gibt weitere
Hinweise und Zeugenaussagen die in diese
Richtung deuten Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft ermitteln fünf
Beschuldigte erste Zeugenaussagen
belasten Sie doch bald muss die Anklage
wieder fallen gelassen werden ja die
Zeugenaussagen kommen aus dem Umfeld der
Beschuldigten ihr Frauen sind darunter
und auch Freunde und nach und nach
ziehen Sie alle Ihre Aussagen zurück
ein Anwalt vermutet das von dritter
Seite Druck auf sie ausgeübt wurde und
so verlaufen die Ermittlungen im Sande
bis heute ist die Tat nicht aufgeklärt
für Adam boscouts Töchter ist das eine
unerträgliche Situation erst mussten sie
den vermeintlichen unfallverkraften den
plötzlichen und vollkommen unerwarteten
Tod eines über alles geliebten Menschen
dann die Nachricht dass er ermordet
wurde dass jemand kaltblütig und
vorsätzlich ihren Vater erschossen hat
und jetzt das Wissen dass der oder die
Täter bisher ungeschoren davon gekommen
sind und vielleicht noch immer in der
Nachbarschaft leben sie würden somit
gleich zweimal traumatisiert eine
wirklich schreckliche Vorstellung keiner
von uns kann sich wohl ausmalen was die
Hinterbliebenen dadurch machen müssen
ein wirklich zermürbender Gedanke eine
der Töchter sagte im Interview es ist
immer wenn ich rausgehe immer so eine
Wut und Angst da diese Person zu sehen
also nicht Angst vor der Person aber
einfach vor mir selber wie ich reagieren
werde was für eine Wut ich in diesem
Moment empfinden werde zu wissen dass
einer der Verdächtigen in meiner Nähe
wohnt ist schlimm
die Suche geht weiter denn mord verjährt
nicht und die Staatsanwaltschaft ist
hartnäckig auch weil sie um die Qual
wissen die Adam Boss kurz Töchter
durchleben nichts und niemand kann ihnen
ihren Vater zurückgeben aber vielleicht
finden sie ihren Frieden wenn der
Gerechtigkeit endlich Genüge getan wird
und das kann man der Familie nur
wünschen
vielen Dank fürs zuhören und hoffentlich
bis zum nächsten mal eure Toni und euer
Mirko
für die Geschichte von Adem Boss Kurt
haben wir uns die zweiteilige Doku der
Fall Adam Bosco aus der Serie Achtung
Fahndung von Bild TV angeschaut weitere
Informationen haben wir in der Gießener
Allgemeinen der Süddeutschen Zeitung
sowie beim NDR gefunden Script und
Postproduktion wakewords Studios München
Redaktion Stefan